hier läuft gerade ein beinharter
machtkampf ruinös sagen manche geht ja
auch was ehrlicherweise für uns alle
wer wird chef von deutschlands
wichtigster und größter volkspartei und
danach vielleicht kannst ich hab's mal
ausgedruckt er der friedrich der ex
blackrock aufsichtsrat der gerne
polarisiert oder der armin der liberale
corona lockerer der der cdu ein
merkelsches weiter so verspricht oder
wird doch der norbert diese außenpolitik
trophy mit außenseiter-chancen ich
erzähl das mal für euch spoiler mit
persönlichen tipp am ende
hallo ich bin florian leu hand und ich
verfolge die cdu ziemlich intensiv seit
ich für das zdf aus berlin über politik
berichten
das ist schon ein paar jahre wer es wird
hellsehen kann ich natürlich nicht aber
ich kann euch sagen was für und was
gegen jeden der kandidaten spricht
politisch und allzu menschlich wenn die
cdu so sieht es aktuell aus im januar
endlich ihre wahl ab hält sich da
zwischen den dreien zu entscheiden ist
gar nicht so leicht sagen mir auch viele
aus der cdu selbst was ich in
hintergrundgesprächen hier in berlin vor
allem ratlosigkeit das liegt vor allem
an den kandidaten selbst schauen wir uns
doch mal genauer die lustigste
geschichte zu märz finde ich ja immer
noch was einmal im interview 2000
behauptet hat in seiner jugend hätte er
so richtig wilde sachen gemacht also
hätte zum beispiel schulterlange haare
tragen
dumm nur dass ich da die jugendfreunde
von merz irgendwie anders erinnern
schulterlange haare
märz nie im leben erst mal spaß beiseite
mehr als letzte große rede im bundestag
ist 18 jahre her seit eineinhalb jahren
steigt ununterbrochen von monat zu monat
die arbeitslosigkeit die antwort der
bundesregierung ist eine neue kommission
ich sage ihnen wir brauchen nicht neue
kommissionen in deutschland sondern wir
brauchen neue arbeitsplätze in diesem
land meine damen
an seine thesen von damals erinnern sich
viele heute noch
da forderte er dass sich die zuwanderer
an die deutsche leitkultur anpassen
sollten oder die deutschen deutschen bis
70 arbeiten und schließlich der hammer
das war hier der bierdeckel auf denen
eine steuererklärung passen müsse märz
hatte klar konservative ideen eine
prägnante sprache und er scheute sich
nicht anzeigen doch 2002 nach der für
die union verlorenen wahl da wurde der
märz abgesagt übrigens von ihr hier
beginn einer besonders innige
feindschaft
märz wechselte später in die wirtschaft
machte geld zum beispiel als
aufsichtsrat bei blackrock nicht
irgendwer sondern die weltgrößte
vermögensverwaltung 7,4 und billionen us
dollar verwalten wir da nur mal zum
vergleich das ist fast doppelt so viel
wie wir alle verdienen also unser
bruttoinlandsprodukt
apropos verdienst der hat ja auch echt
kohle gemacht den kosten hat der märz
anfang des jahres aufgegeben und wenn
wir ihn heute darauf ansprechen
hier geht der norden ist zwar das sind
18 wollte der millionär dann zurück an
die macht als angebot an alle die von
michaels mitte kurs die schnauze voll
hatten nur er verlor knapp gegen sie
hier
warum sollte es diesmal klappen
eins muss man ihm lassen märz kann
begeistern wenn er in ostdeutschland bei
der cdu-basis auftritt dann bekommen wir
nachher solche stimmen vor der kamera
spricht meine sprache unterstützt meint
denkt er weiß was so will er hat
vorstellungen erinnert mich um
auch wenn es eher ein gefühl ist dass
der märz vermittelt als konkrete inhalte
märz steht für den fokus auf wirtschaft
hier neulich hat er zum beispiel
getwittert nach der pandemie sollten
alle staatlichen leistungen auf den
prüfstand
so was kommt an im wirtschaftsflügel der
union seine größten fans aber sitzen bei
den jungen für dich märz bei der umfrage
der jungen union eine absolute mehrheit
erreicht er ist auch in allen 17
landesverbänden der jungen union auf dem
ersten platz und hat daher meine und die
unterstützung der jungen union auf dem
diese auf dem bundesparteitag die junge
union hat als einziger einen
mitgliederentscheid veranstaltet da lag
der märz klar vorn wobei nicht
überbewerten darf man das nicht
wahlbeteiligung gerade mal 20 prozent
von allen mitgliedern und auf dem
parteitag ist die ad hoc ein machtfaktor
also was man zu den märz festhalten muss
er mobilisiert seine fans aber nicht nur
auf seine gegner
ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen wie
sehr sie den märz bei der spd die daumen
drücken denn wenn der antritt könnten
sich viele in deutschland nach einem
gegenmodell sehen ein cdu-chef märz das
ist die größte hoffnung für jemanden wie
olaf scholz
denn merz der bricht mit der ära merkel
und scholz der steht er für ein weiter
so was aber viele vielleicht gerade auch
wollen
neulich habe ich den märz interview da
wollte der ernsthaft mit mir über die
zahl der fragen verhandeln das erlebe
ich sonst in berlin nicht aber es zeigt
eben der märz ist misstrauisch geworden
weil ihm regelmäßig was rausrutscht was
nachher nicht so gut ankommt und da war
die empörung über einen satz in der bild
der märz habe ja kein problem mit einem
schwulen kanzler so lange sich das im
rahmen der geltenden gesetze bewegung
und solange es nicht kinder betreffe was
hat das mit schwulsein zu tun und dann
war da sein ärger über die verschiebung
des parteitags im dezember und das
versteht keiner warum das jetzt vom
vierten dezember auf den 16 januar
verschoben werden soll
ich halte meine vermutung aufrecht dass
die verlegung des parteitages mit corona
wenig und mit anderen erwägungen sehr
viel zu tun hat diese vermutung liegt
auf der hand und die wird auch von einer
großen zahl von beobachtern in berlin
geteilt plötzlich witterte märz eine
verschwörung und das so vehement dass
mancher ihn schon als dem deutschen
trump bezeichnete ernsthaft das ist ein
absurder vergleich märz ist jetzt keine
serien münchner keine gnadenloser
populist oder auch kein rassistischer
die einzige gemeinsamkeit ist auch märz
macht jetzt wahlkampf gegen die führung
gegen das establishment der eigenen
partei und das könnte im wahlkampf echt
zum problem werden
armin laschet der ist ja ein bekannter
hochschullehrer
wusstet ihr nicht doch in der tat der
war mal lehrbeauftragte an der
hochschule in aachen hat dann wird er
bei seiner klausur in seiner studenten
verloren und als gute seele ja trotzdem
benotet leute nur er hatte 35 noten
vergeben bei 28 teilnehmern
das kann also raus die noten affäre des
armin laschet 2018 als der cdu vorsitz
das letzte mal frei war da zuckte er
noch zurück diesmal hat sich doch wir
können und müssen unsere partei und
unser land wieder zusammenführen und
dafür will ich kandidieren als
vorsitzender der cdu deutschlands hat
das war mal 2005 der erste
landesminister für integration überhaupt
aus der zeit stammt sein image als
liberaler und später seine erste große
niederlage 2010 nämlich dann wollte er
cdu-chef von nrw werden und verlor
ausgerechnet gegen norbert reitz kinder
bei zudem kommen wir gleich laschet
karriere verlief also auch nicht gerade
die nicht aber er bekam und er nutzte
seine zweite chance 2017 da wurde er
entgegen vieler prognosen der
ministerpräsident von nordrhein
westfalen
[Applaus]
heute ist ein guter tag für nordrhein
westfalen
laschet wird oft unterschätzt genau wie
merkel damals
dabei hat er schon mal eine echte wahl
gewonnen das ist manchmal ziemlich
ermüdend wenn man mit nach schätzen
leuten im hintergrund spricht wie oft
sie einen darauf hinweisen aber sie
haben ja recht das hat laschet den
anderen beiden voraus und er hat
jemanden für sein team gewinnen können
der jungen beliebt ist armin laschet und
ich wir hatten in den vergangenen jahren
auch mal unsere differenzen
doch genau darum geht es bei einer
volkspartei brücken bauen zwischen
unterschiedlichen positionen und
generation geschickter schachzug hier
der liberale lastet und da der
konservativere sparen
noch im frühjahr hätte ich wohl gesagt
die beiden haben echten vorteil und habe
ich echt gesagt ich sehe trotzdem einen
kleinen vorteil bei dem team aus armin
laschet und jens spahn einfach weil
diese beiden eben als team gut
funktionieren und eben die beiden lager
die beiden flügel der partei dass
konservative und das liberale lager
beide gemeinsam ansprechen können war
ich zu voreilig dann nämlich kam zu den
landesvater laschet ziemlich hart in der
korona krise
ja in der korona krise da liebs
wiederstedt nicht so gut mal verrutscht
die um die maske dann lief ein toller
auftritt ziemlich mäßig dann lieferte
auch laschet halbsätze die waren alles
andere als glücklich hier im juni zum
beispiel frage meiner zdf kollegin
nicole was sagt der krone ausbruch in
gütersloh aus über die lockerung
strategie von laschet darüber überhaupt
nichts aus weil rumänen und bulgaren da
eingereist sind unter der virus herkommt
das wird überall passieren
wie bitte ich dachte das virus kommt aus
china und außerdem war es doch sowieso
schon hier
laschet musste das später richtig
stellen wie so manches in diesem sommer
und seine kampagne geriet echt unter
druck bis ihm dann im august
merkel selbst zur seite sprang wenn sie
das größte land bundesland der
bundesrepublik deutschland regieren in
einer koalition cdu fdp die effizient
arbeitet die nicht durch besonders viele
streitereien auffällt dann ist das
zumindest ein rüstzeug das durchaus
gewicht hat laschet ja wäre vermutlich
merkels kandidat wie merkel nur in
männlich lästern manche
vor caron hätte ich gesagt ein echtes -
jetzt ist merkel so beliebt wie nie und
es ist vielleicht sogar ein plus
geworden die frage ist nur wofür steht
laschet eigentlich also außer für einen
kurs der mitte so richtig kann das
ehrlich gesagt niemand beantworten und
das spricht nicht gerade für ihn
guten abend herr röttgen guten abend
norbert röttgen vielen dank dass sie da
sind herzlich willkommen
guten morgen der taucht gerade so oft im
fernsehen auf das man schon denkt er
hätte irgend ein wichtiges amt in der
regierung tatsächlich ist er bloß
vorsitzende des auswärtigen ausschusses
des deutschen bundestages können weiß
was die medien lieben muss nicht nur
sowas hier guten abend herr fornoff
guten abend im spiel vielen dank für die
einladung sondern auch dass er sofort
rede bereit ist es gibt eine eilmeldung
wir schicken eine sms an röttgen und
sofort gibt es die zusage für den
perfekten o-ton röttgen kann reden und
er hat einen riecher für die richtigen
themen
vielleicht ist sein größter pluspunkt
aber noch ein anderer dass er nämlich
als cdu-chef gar nicht unbedingt
kanzlerkandidat werden will hat er
mehrfach so gesagt darum muss jeder
cdu-vorsitzender immer diese beiden
rollen annehmen auch wollen und können
also cdu vorsitzender zu sein und
kanzlerkandidat sein aber auch
cdu-vorsitzender ohne kanzlerkandidat zu
werden damit ist redcoon der ideale
cdu-chef für alle die sich eigentlich
einen anderen kanzlerkandidaten wünschen
nämlich dem csu chef markus söder
2006 da sollte und wollte röttgen
der hauptgeschäftsführer des bdi werden
des bundesverbandes der deutschen
industrie klassischer lobby job nur
gleichzeitig wollte er auch sein
bundestagsmandat behalten moment ein
lobbyist im bundestag wird können
brauchte ein paar tage bis auch er
einsah dass das keine so gute idee war
und in kandidatur für den bdi aufgabe
übrigens lobbyismus und politik da kommt
demnächst ein video auf diesem kanal
gleiches muster 2012 da wollte röttgen
ministerpräsident von nrw werden aber
gleichzeitig erstmals einen
ministerposten in berlin behalten die
wahl endete in einem desaster 2012 in
nrw das schlechteste ergebnis was die
cdu dort jemals einfuhr dieser wahltag
heute ist für die cdu nordrhein
westfalen für mich persönlich für unsere
mitstreiterin mitstreiter ein bitterer
tag
es ist eine eindeutige klare niederlage
die wir heute erlitten haben nach diesem
desaster wurde übrigens röttgen
persönlich von merkel als minister
entlassen
als einziger alle anderen warten selbst
und lassen ich habe heute vormittag mit
dem herrn bundespräsidenten gesprochen
und ich habe ihm gemäß artikel 64 des
grundgesetzes vorgeschlagen
norbert röttgen von seinen aufgaben als
bundesumweltminister zu entbinden
aber das ist vielleicht nicht mal sein
größtes problem sondern eher dass ihm
die namhaften unterstützer fehlen also
bis auf einen natürlich ich bin norbert
rennt
norbert röttgen warum er nicht ich habe
einen guten grund ist warum
neulich sprach ich mit jemandem aus der
unionsfraktion jetzt nicht unwichtig der
sagte mir er würde jahres gewählt dabei
hat sich ja sowieso keine chance
und dann wäre die stimme doch verschenkt
also gut auf die gefahr hin dass ich
falsch liege ich lege mich einfach mal
fest ich glaube das risiko mit einem
kandidaten märz das ist mittlerweile
vielen in der cdu klar geworden das wäre
wohl zu groß dass man auf einen solitär
setzt wie norbert röttgen glaube ich
auch er nicht bleibt also einer übrig
armin laschet
aber wenn armin laschet gewinnen dann
nicht wegen armin laschet sondern er
trotz armin laschet und vielleicht auch
wegen jens spahn in der macht finden
zumindest viele in der cdu gerade eine
echt gute figur und könnte dem laschet
die entscheidenden stimmen liefern
aber wer weiß kann auch viel passieren
und vielleicht gibt es ja doch noch
einigen überraschungskandidaten sowieso
ist offen wie es danach weitergeht ob
sich die cdu hinter dem gewinner dann
versammelt und wer kanzlerkandidat wird
da hat ja auch dieser markus wieder noch
ein wörtchen mitzureden
und die läuft die bundestagswahl wenn
der merkel bonus wegfällt
was meint ihr schreibt es mir doch mal
in die kommentare habt ihr einen
lieblingskandidaten oder einen favoriten
weitere folgen von inside politics gibt
es übrigens auch am besten einfach mal
unseren kanal abonnieren